[Musique]
quand j'ai lu le titre du projet et qui
s'appelle des cercles immense je me suis
dit ça c'est un projet génial pas pour
ce qui concerne claude nicolas ledoux
c'était peut-être pas simplement un rêve
mais plus un projet je vaux transition
ne convient plus haut face à l'axé
[Musique]
on travaille sur le 2ème demi cercle qui
s'affiche à derrière moi donc sur la le
cercle immense ce chantier qui prend
forme sous nos yeux et je suis
particulièrement heureux d'accueillir
gilles clément
une vidéo et un dossier écrit face au
jury de spécialistes
les élèves paysagistes ont imaginé des
jardins qui soit à la fois inventif et
respectueux de l'environnement avec
tellement d'inspiration qu'au lieu de
neuf jardins éphémères
onze ont été retenus j'ai l'impression
que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui sont encore
plus enseigne un discours de gilles
clément que peut-être que nous on
l'était parce qu'à l'époque on n'était
peut-être plus attirés par les grands
concepts les grandes clés la maîtrise de
tout est là il ya un vrai reversement
sur le chantier la nouvelle vision des
jardins s'applique déjà
ainsi pour créer le nouvel espace on a
remodelé le terrain en gardant la terre
d'origine
c'est vrai que c'est un parti pris des
parts de ne pas vouloir évacuer la terre
étant ramené et la terre a cette
capacité en fait à une banque de graines
dans la terre dans la prairie fleurie ce
qu'on appelle la prairie fleurie
il ya une grande partie des pelouses qui
vont se ressemer naturellement par cette
banque de graines et donc le dessin très
géométrique
en fait je l'assumé parce que c'est
l'histoire du site et après moi ce que
je trouve beau c'est cette confrontation
entre un projet imaginé par le doubs et
le vivant qui va venir jouer dans dents
dans ces grands jardins et donc c'est
vrai que j'assume aussi côté très
dessinée du projet n'en laissant une
grande liberté au végétal on est
peut-être dans un espace contraint parce
qu'on est dans un cercle immense complet
que vous pourrez dire ça c'est une
limite
mais le vent connaît pas et cette limite
et les insectes non plus les oiseaux
n'ont plus les graines des plantes non
plus et ainsi de suite
donc on peut dire que d'accord il y à ce
dessin qu'on verra toujours celui que
nicolas ledoux d'accord mais quelque
chose d'autre qui est très très
important aujourd'hui se passe et refait
un dessin qui est mobile qui est sûre
jean qui est de type organique et avec
des jardiniers qui ont compris
l'importance de maintenir cette
diversité
[Musique]
loin très loin d'arc et senans cette
fois le directeur de la saline est venu
rendre visite à gilles clément et il est
tout de suite immergé dans la vie de la
vallée
la chenille vedette du jardin est en
plein repas elle est là il est en train
de se montrer comme une star et elle est
donc
et les chenilles qui ont cette marque là
sont repérés par les oiseaux comme
poison d'accord donc elle ne mange pas
ne les mange pas je découvre votre
refuge mais refusent un point seulement
la vallée et pluvieuse et froide ce
matin là mais les échanges entre les
deux hommes pointent les connexions
entre l'architecte visionnaire et le
jardinier philosophe moi je suis rentré
dans mon jardin par les insectes
samedi lens et nice 3-2 le doubs ah oui
c'est un monde isolé du monde c'est un
peuple qui se développe qui fait germer
tous les germes de la terre semblable la
bei qui collige de fleur en fleur
renault m